hello there
what did you find this beast I've never
been with any woman but Cersei no much
happier daylight if you know many men I
suppose not
women horses has anyone ever told you
you're as boring as you are ugly provoke
me to anger I already have look at you
all ready to chop my head off you think
lady Stark is going to want a giant
towheaded plank following around for the
rest of her life
one withered Winterfell how do you know
because I visited Winterfell I've
noticed your dour head smacking into the
archways me ah Renly really he wasn't
fit to rule or anything more important
than a 12-course meal shut your mouth
why he preferred curly-haired little
girls like Loras Tyrell you're thought
so much madman it's a shame the throne
isn't made out of [ __ ] they'd have
never got him off it don't blame him I
don't blame you either don't get that
you save your love
you're supposed to get me to King's
Landing in one piece not going so well
is it
[Music]
are you sure why not related ever since
I've returned every Lannister I've seen
has been a miserable pain in my ass
maybe you're allowed to you've got the
hair for it nothing looks milady
I promise I'll serve you well see it's a
good laugh you'll get along I just as
soon Sansa was dead why would you seem
that in my experience girls like her
don't live very long I don't think you
know many girls like her have you ever
met the blackfish no is even more
stubborn than you are what are you doing
what I think you know I truly don't we
have never had a conversation last this
long without you insulting me not once
you wanted to insult you no good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]